chaque concitoyen de la russie chers
anciens combattants chers amis de tout
mon coeur je vous adresse mes
félicitations pour ce jour de la
victoire pour nous tous c'est une fête
la plus importante la plus chère
toujours nous commémorons cet
anniversaire avec toute notre pays tous
ensemble l' importance spirituelle de ce
jour est très grand et notre attitude
envers cette fête est sacré c'est notre
fierté c'est l'histoire de notre pays
l'histoire de chaque famille une partie
de notre âme partagé par nos pères nos
grands pères nous ressentons avec
beaucoup d'acuité l'importance de cette
fête nous honorons la mémoire de ceux
qui sont partis
nous regardons les photos jaunies
nous souhaitons une bonne vie à tous
ceux qui vivent aujourd'hui nous
respectons la grande génération des
vainqueurs et qu'ils ont fait pour notre
patrie ce qui ne peut pas être mesurée
payer ils sont sauvés notre patrie et la
vie des générations à venir
ils ont défendu l'europe et lille on se
regardait la paix ils ont restauré les
villes et les villages
ils ont réalisé des grandes acquis nos
vous honorons l'exploit énorme du peuple
soviétique qui était composée de toutes
ethnies de toutes nationalités coude à
coude
ils ont combattu le temps n'a pas effacé
leur dignité et leur force de l'âme qui
est fait d'acier
chers amis ici devant la muraille du
kremlin
c'est une place sacré pour nous tous
devant cette flamme éternelle à la
mémoire de ceux qui ont perdu leur vie
ici nous rendons hommage au soldat
inconnu au héros qui sont restés dans
des tombes inconnu ce moscou smolensk
stalingrad course que sébastopol minsk
et kiev et riga berlin et vienne 1
common paul quéveau sur les rives de la
nive à du danube de la vistule des
millions de ceux qui sont guéris et qui
n'ont pas vu ce jour de la victoire tant
rêver et ils ont pu l'espérance de
revenir chez eux ils ont combattu pour
cette victoire jusqu'à la dernière
goutte du sang ils ont perdu leur vie
pour que nous et les générations à venir
nos fils nos enfants nos filles vivent
en paix ils ont sauvegardé la paix c'est
l'exploit du soldat soviétique heures
nous nous plions devant la mémoire de
ceux qui sont péri devant la mémoire des
fils des filles des pères des mères un
des grands pères
des maris des femmes des frères des
soeurs des camarades du régiment des
proches de famille des amis respectant
une minute de silence
chers amis 75 ans sont passés après la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale la
grande guerre patriotique nous allons
commémorer cet anniversaire comme la
tradition le veut avec toute la dignité
devant notre fierté devant ceux qui sont
tombés et qui ont fait la grande
victoire
nous allons organiser le défilé
militaire sur la place rouge et la
marche du régiment immortel pour
témoigner de ce lien historique
ils ont combattu contre la mort pour la
vie et nous nous alignons sur leur
dignité
nous sommes réunis dans cette histoire
dans cet espoir dans ses aspirations
la responsabilité pour le présent et
pour l'avenir un nos savons et nous
avons cette assurance que nous sommes un
vicieux invincible
quand nous sommes ensemble bonne fête
bonjour de la victoire pour 1